how does one put their anus in friend
group
shush hang on that's my current approach
shot at
oh hello this is
yeah i'm being shot sorry uh i have the
game
zero friend servers well i don't know
man hang on oh i haven't turned on the
session i'm being murdered right now
just hold your freaking horse
yes i mean i have to be in the game for
you to join me in well that's wait are
we starting from the beginning though or
no we're not we're start i have a it's
like a tutorial for the first
hour
this is shut up we don't need to know
how to play we're just going to jump in
an hour okay shut up okay are you in
oh there you are oh hey guys hey
hey what's up you look good how's it
going
hey i gotta mess with my settings for a
while hang on
okay those are easy oh my god what is
with games and having mouse
sensitivities that don't make any
goddamn sense i don't know t to open the
build menu got it
right p as in
buildings t as in titties tea as in
tilden got it you guys don't have guns
this might be a pr oh you have a guy oh
god
hey what's up i have a gun
how's it going you have a gun is that
good oh you look so angry bob
yeah that's it can i hurt you i almost
just shot you in the head i don't know
if that's a bad idea or not all right
let's shoot okay wait no okay i feel
great i was way do you shot oh no
but your mark with the hat yes you have
a hat too yeah well you look kind of
angry wait are you
dumb ass eyes is that you yeah yes me
what's with your eyes what if i touch
this handle no uh what is that the
transmission the transmission handle uh
yeah i don't oh that's the direction
that you go the one on the right is the
brake to stop the oh okay the front is
just a horn
oh hey how do i get out of here
good freaking luck dude i can't jump do
i have ammo or do i just have unlimited
ammo with oh it's unlimited unlimited
all right i'm going to shoot
ah that's pretty fun whoa
whoa
what is this
so this is where you add train cars i've
never seen that oh holy [ __ ] is that you
is that you stuck in the track right now
wayne i'm pressing space and nothing's
happening wait you can still jump down
here yeah of course you can still jump
why can't i jump down here legitimately
did you rebind your jump in the field
test
wait figure this out silently no one
cares
my space works for typing but not for
jumping oh man this guy mark what is
this game okay so this is void train
it's a lot like raft um where
you build more onto your train instead
of it being a raft and you have
craftables and in the next area you guys
are gonna see a whole world of cool
stuff
guys there's german over here his weight
going infantly
yes i'm coming back i'm reloading in so
my space bar will work okay explosion
yeah i know stuff i know stuff about
sass me chat you all stole i wasn't
jumping you sure she's from mark you're
german you speak german right oh yeah
that's me
affluenza is that a german word
no
i believe that is when you're so
affluent that you're dying of being too
affluent oh no forget the train part of
this where are you all at hold on i'm
exploring it did you i mean did you
explore this area mark is there a
resource i have never been here so when
i saved last i was not here this is a
new area there was a stairs
there are numerous reasons why you're an
idiot right now
i know but i don't want to hear it yeah
there's items that you can pick up on
the ground every once in a while um but
the main stuff comes i say we skip over
this
hey uh bob come over here look uh look
out there
oh
is that good oh shoot at it
i don't wha i don't
want to shoot at it come on wait wait
from the train where are you guys so i
can see what you're shooting at south uh
south of it yeah on the on the west side
of the platform oh i'm going to go touch
it
mark the pokeball whoa what is your dick
chord how do you walk with the [ __ ] i
ran out of space
man i'm really glad i have one of those
too
look i'm slightly further than you
uh-huh wow good for you man good for you
why is yours longer than ours
i don't know he's just bad
okay well
i feel like i know what's going on all
right good now let's get back to the
train mark i'm gonna throw the wood that
i got into the abyss okay why would you
do that you could put it in the storage
oh okay well i don't know i don't know
what i'm supposed to do here i thought i
was just doing whatever i wanted
what's the illuminati eyeball equal sign
in front of us that is exactly what you
said it was it's the illuminati eyeballs
if i jump off here do i remain strapped
to the train only one way to find out
all right baby
oh thank god
hey look guys a water ski oh
yeah i know you might want to go
[Laughter]
get up up up go up up go up swim up and
get here oh yeah i gotta sleep i gotta
slow it down that's right i gotta i
gotta slow down the uh i can't get back
oh jesus christ get on the train
okay here you go let's go
yeah be aware there are uh horrible
things i have 76 health now is that good
that's fine you can eat less than 100
get health uh if you look around you see
all the debris there are small glowing
items around those think of those are
like the scavengeables in how do you
grasp you will swim get them you go get
them boy
oh i'm going all right
you got it don't worry
hey mark am i holding a gun or am i
pointing my finger are you pointing your
fingers at me that's not good
that's not good
i can't turn
my mouse and i'm stuck oh okay i
couldn't jump
oh hey i'm unbroken maybe i would say
don't jump off don't jump off the train
with your pistol in your hands i think
is what i was running into there okay
all right we're duly noted so um what we
do once we get materials is we can craft
them on the workbench uh and then we can
research more uh more items and uh
whatnot
oh god they didn't like that they didn't
like that oh you killed one tadpole they
all started coming for the eggs we're
the eggs
never mind they're gone we scared them
off so that big thing you can kill it
oh and those little things
they have like uh biological goodies
meat meats what you uh humans call meat
maybe they'll swarm and try to eat bob
we can grab them
yeah i know hang me off the back like
bait i mean i can only fall off the
train my space bar is not working again
so i want to fall off the job
like look when i'm out here i can space
my way up but on there i can't jump
maybe i've got like multiplayer settings
where it's like restricted jumping
abilities
oh
hey wait how you doing
you seem to be kind of just hanging down
underneath
who don't like you don't like you okay i
can jump again oh no i've lost the
ability to jump i'm like wade all right
so basically you
you smelt you smelt in the schmelty
okay
and then you create metal and then you
can use the metal to create components
like nuts and bolts and uh different
things and eventually we're gonna need a
lot of those because we will need to
upgrade the train and add more train
cars to it
uh all right he's fine yeah i'm fine
i'm doing something i don't know what
i'm doing i think you put fuel in and
you're making copper
okay cool
give me your meat
i thought i could get this meat hey
hey
hey
no mommy you got meat mark there's a
bigger manta ray to the right ow yeah
don't don't worry about that that's fine
oh he looks fun he is fun
as far as the lore of this game i don't
have a clue i don't have a goddamn clue
well clearly we're space
trained pirates
obviously need to get back to their
grass roots
hey mark is that thing behind us a
problem
uh don't worry about that i actually
have no idea what that's about oh well
then yeah i'm just gonna ignore that
then yeah okay also with the big
floating glowing thing yeah yeah yeah
it's totally fine wait wait wait
i need your delicious meats
my ass cheeks are you where are you oh
god
yeah he's uh he's big and tough and hard
to kill and hurt you really badly now
i've also got no health you're gonna
need some food in the lab you can make
things like chemicals and sterilizers
and uh
grease and whatnot if you want grease
but in the uh in the workbench you can
actually make consumables and bandages
which you need sterilizers and leather
for
and guess where you get leather hey i
got leather you also need food and water
if it's very tiny but if you look in the
bottom left you'll notice that you have
a health and then you have a little
water icon and a little soup icon i
don't seem to have those icons i don't
see those two either oh you must not be
hungry maybe i'm fine yeah when you get
hungry they will appear i think
oh your meat is so far from me
that's what she said
all the time
so when is the train
you hit the brakes but otherwise we're
just going to go to us
yeah like so the station we'll just get
to the station like we were at yeah yeah
pretty much you can make the trailer
floating out dude gun it gun it okay hit
that middle pump
no i'm hanging off the back bro all
right you'll see around do you want
copper bars more iron bars more both
you'll need lots of both so just make
make as much copper as you have that
other chemical for and then uh you know
you know you know
oh
freaking nailed you do i have to stay in
the menu
uh no you can leave it'll make oh yeah
if we're going at speed and you hit a
rock it's gonna hurt okay so you're just
gonna be dodging bounce
it's fine hang on i can catch it oh wait
no i forgot that it was going fast oh
god
are we all stuck off of it now oh no
yeah
i think if we
can rope ourselves
i'm back i'm back i'm back i'm back i'm
back
i'm back i'm back oh my little flesh
gloves
give me your meat and flesh ah
i like this my little blood crafties oh
i like it not a lot i need more of these
alien looking things what yeah what
exactly are we looking for i guess i
don't know what the priorities are you
need you need pretty much everything
once we get more something else dirty
ice yeah yeah yeah slurp that dirtiest
little ice yeah
am i not gonna get sick from this dirty
ice do i just drink it with no
consequences drink it up baby
watch out you got you got predator
coming in you got predators
i'm high not fine
i don't really really twisting around
here
yeah okay there we go
baby so do i eat raw meat or you're
going to eat raw meat you can cook it
too i think if you on the workbench is
like consumable no it's not there
somewhere you can cook meat i know you
can
oh you killed it
wait i'm hitting i'm reversing
we need that fat
that's some good [ __ ]
give me more of your delicious meats
i think i got it all all right fair
enough do i need to research something
yeah we need to research something i'm
gonna eat i'm gonna eat a meat you eat a
meat you eat it up
that hurt my health that lowered my
health no you don't want it did you eat
raw meat
maybe okay that's your
okay
you know you know
yeah sure also did you notice how did i
open okay guys look ahead
hey look they were going into the celtic
knot yeah sure we are oh yeah oh that
seems like a good thing i've never been
to celtic but it seems like a nice place
oh it's a lovely place you're gonna love
it i've got also your ice
and free organics too you can drink the
pure ice the organics you can eat
straight up and then um we can build a
kitchen once we get enough parts i just
i almost have enough i just need to go
all right more things
i just don't need that don't even have
that that's pretty fun oh wait there's i
have okay i'm gonna build a kitchen
oh i feel like we're
really running out of space yeah this is
why we needed oh it's dark oh dear
oh oh wait
roller coaster time oh it's nick
oh hey what's up dudes
so
is there like bad guys here or something
kitchen
there you go guys oh [ __ ] dude kitchen
i'm gonna cook that meat
right yeah um i don't know if there's
bad guys here
there are items usually you can scavenge
around i see something
i got wood and not like the morning wood
kind but like the kanye craft
excuse me
jesus
i've never seen this before
i found a slot machine but i don't have
enough tokens oh i can give you some of
mine how many tokens do i have i don't
know how many tokens you have i probably
have zero tokens
i found i found a sacrificial table i
don't know if we need that whoa
also a radio that's kirk her chirping
your chirping radio huh
maybe i don't know about that okay
where's my mouse uh
interesting who has a metal bar do
anyone have a metal bar
i need a metal
i have three copper i have an iron bar
i need yeah i need an iron bar what are
you trying to do i'm gonna are you okay
i'm gonna try to add a train car
but i need one more bike like do this
yeah that did it
oh how much metal do we have
three copper bars and whatever i crafted
before did you make any metal bars like
iron bars
copper
you told me to make as much copper as i
had the stuff for ah i said this but as
many as the green ah god damn it that's
what i did i don't have any iron bars
three copper
yeah
i got some
copper is metal then he said iron
all right i agree so
we can't add a wagon because we don't
have metal bars well i've got i've got
one scrap iron i could give somebody if
you guys have scrap iron to make one uh
bob do you have any scrap
uh what does that look like
it looks like i have two scrap needles
uh give me the scrap needles yeah i
think that still might not be enough
let me look
oh i just took someone's steak whoops
that's fine i'm making those so you need
iron right so i should make some copper
bars if you can make some iron bars
no car no no wait no i can make one iron
bar for you uh smaller
if we find one more scrap metal
i know who's out here who's using my
kitchen right now
me i was putting i'm trying to put fuel
in but it's not wanting my fuel yeah
what is with this sacrifice table what
is with this
i don't know man
seems good though right uh-huh yeah it
seems real good it seems really pretty
cool right oh sacrifice me
hey mark we have five uh copper bars is
that what you need ah
no
well okay shoot sorry sorry i was just
trying to help
oh my god there's a pig slot machine
what is this
that's what you guys were talking about
it's okay i don't know what it's for
but i wish it took copper bars we have a
lot of those
shut up shut up shut up shut your
hormones what are cover bars for mark if
we have so many why do you have
something for wiring they're for wires
don't be mean and answer me i don't like
that wires i do can you be mean and
answer me
why i found one more scrap metal does
anybody guess we can make one more iron
bar we can make one more i still don't
know if it's enough all right i think we
have three bars which is not enough
[ __ ]
but it's okay we'll just go to the next
station and then we'll be ready there oh
bob i got more stuff for you hang on if
you're if you're cooking
yeah i'm cooking baby there's that
you're the cook here's organics
right behind you
we need more i wish food healed us
can i just say that you need to auto
healed i went back to 100 just from
existing i'm at 50 which i guess is
better than not yeah you you got it up
out there i wanna you go oh that that
thing really wanted you all right i'm
gonna hit the break i'm gonna get going
okay
yeah sounds good i just researched uh
chemicals
oh wait
aggression indicator
oh yeah bob this is what you missed when
you were in the box last time was our
takeoff oh yeah that's pretty fun i
thought we were a lot faster last time
but maybe not i mean this is pretty fast
i don't know what to tell you
sorry i don't want to make anyone too
jealous but i'm slowly eating a bento
box for lunch over here and it's just
delicious oh my god i am jealous i
actually did i know i know we just got
spots for it but i actually did sign up
for noom and it's very interesting
they don't know that that episode
doesn't come out yet right yeah
cigarette secrets
you're gonna get us fired from podcasts
right however that works
our sponsors don't like free promotion
honestly that's actually a thing i don't
know why it's a thing but that is the
thing they don't like you talking about
it in any way possible so i shouldn't
talk about the delicious taste of
coca-cola i mean
probably not i just
don't talk about us love coke
i guess not got an email uh i'm gonna
die in two minutes
mr coke's gonna get down here
it's gonna make me overdose
i'm backing up i'm backing up i'm back
was it the yelling that helped oh yeah
it was though
it was actually that that really helped
okay i really need wood why isn't there
more space wood hey space wood
guys i found space wood
yeah it's really
it's really easy to miss stuff because
it's often behind the things like
hitting yeah you gotta swim around yeah
hey guys i got spacewood
i need to make space
you know what i'm saying
or something i can't get okay thank god
we're not going that fast
bastard that's right you better run
video games
someone take the metal
the iron bars i have not
and it should i left it in that chest i
put it back in that chest i believe i
think someone i have three scrap metals
on me
i'm gonna make iron you just remember
that you guys hear that noise
no
the one that sounds kind of ominous and
scary yeah the ones that sounds like a
giant creature growling to the right
okay okay
i definitely heard that one
i'm assuming it's fine that's oh you
guys missed all this wooden metal over
here stop it i am stopping it sorry i
distract i mean you guys were distracted
by the giant almost noise and didn't
look yeah we were but admittedly that
was all of your fault true yeah that was
my fault all right someone grabbed my
medal
don't hurt my metal
we're going back yeah we are oh
hold on
wait no wait oh wait you need back
sorry sorry sorry sorry i'm sorry i'm
sorry
man he's hard to kill i have 12 health
hey wait do you want to go get those
medals yeah
they're almost over the traffic when
it's close that way we can get it okay
yeah wait baiting in i got there i'm
pretty good
i got him i got him okay
oh don't worry i came for the metal oh
over here
i forgot the thing keeps moving after
i'm off hey he's dead i got it
oh nice
oh he could not have died any closer
than he did
so nice of him dudes
i have six uh scrap metals and bunch of
leathers
oh my god form them into copper bars
copper sure
you no longer need iron
no man no
no yes man i don't understand sarcasm so
i'll make him into copper like you said
okay
i believe that you were actually doing
it i was about to and you stopped me
oh it's too late guys you don't even
know how to turn it around what wood
metal wood metal metal right metal right
metal right
i got it i'm on my way where oh
i didn't cord for a minute
i just wanted the metal i went uh-huh
yeah i imagine that this shark is not
the only threat that's going to be
occurring
what do you mean now we've pretty much
beaten the game at this point
oh yeah oh i have 15 health is that good
oh yeah oh
yeah uh mark i crafted like four more
iron bars i think three or something i
love that about iron i didn't even do
copper this stuff
hey i'm back
i just got sucked down and it scared me
i'm gonna kick this into high gear here
that seems like a good idea while i'm
out here in the middle of these
asteroids oh yeah i'm kicking it in a
high
dodge
make sure to get that metal
which one all of it i'm gonna i gotta
make another storage block my my dudes
wait no wait wait wait wait no wait just
hold on just hold on a little bit longer
okay hold on a little bit longer we're
gonna get we're out i hit a rock we're
gonna get to the next station we're
gonna be build a new train it's gonna be
bigger and better it's gonna be so
i wonder what the ragdoll physics is
like when he passes out
oh god stop hitting the rock
i just want the materials wait why are
you having so much trouble dodging the
rocks oh it's like someone is speeding
up the train the whole time you think it
goes extra fast well we offer that rock
buddy oh god i missed the wood
oh hey it deposited its meat on the
train how convenient oh that's nice nice
of it that was nice of it
hey hey oh i don't have enough space god
damn it
there's no i'm gonna i'm pretty tight on
face okay i'm gonna come back now this
is too scary ooh never mind i see
something to grab and i like grabbing
you do like grabbing oh i got a medal i
got a high speed medal that's why they
call you grabby barnes grab minions
god the rocks in my face lord grabber
it's better than my old nickname of lord
smacked in the face
on the space coming back
where'd all the food go do you guys need
no metal on the left metal on the left i
can't grab it
i have not touched food oh i have a
bunch of grilled organics
i grabbed the metal on the left despite
not being able to grab it good job buddy
keep it up out there oh we're getting
leached
we're getting leash
what is that do you see the under the
kitchen do you see that mark what
what is that is that just for me
i don't see anything i feel like the
dead body of a leech flailing around
underneath the kitchen really awkwardly
anymore
metal in a box i love that
all of our shit's very full we need more
boxes we should use all of our iron
immediately hold on we're almost to the
next station
you know how i know
no no cause i can see it
[Music]
foreign